المال الراتب الثروه تمثل بدورها الطموح
والاستمراريه والتقدم نحو مستقبل
الاقتصادي افضل للافراد والمجتمعات فتكيف
مع التقلبات الاقتصاديه الحاده التي
يشهدها العلم قد يستغرق شهورا بالنسبه
للموظف وبالنسبه لرواد الاعمال الصغيره
يمكن ان تبتدئ الاشهر الى سنوات منصه
كرانش بيس تقول ان تمويل الشركات الناشئه
في الولايات المتحده كندا انخفض بنسبه 50%
على اساسن سنوي استثمر في نفسك نصيحه
بسيطه قد تبدو رقيقه من كثره تكرارها مع
ذلك يبدو انها مفتاح النجاح ولا بديل لها
خصوصا في الوقت الحالي الملياردير
والمستثمر الامريكي يقول ان تعلم كيف تكتب
وكيف تتحدث يمكن ان يجعلنا اكثر قيمه
وثراء بنسبه 50% اما نحن عليه الان في
2023 اداره الاعمال قد تكون مهمه شاقه لكن
مع قوي ومدرب يمكن الاعتماد عليه قادر على
التعامل بواقعيه مع المتغيرات ربما تكون
الامور اسهل نسبيا
ماذا قال ايضا مليارديرات العالم حول طرق
جمع الثروه في عالم المالح على سرحان
ملياردير حول العالم حتى ديسمبر 2022 بحسب
مجله فوكس جميعهم يتبنون مفاهيم وشعارات
محدده يعتقدون انها السبب في نجاحهم
وتحقيقهم للثروات واليكم اقتباسات بعض
اشهرهم من اشهر اقوال بيل جيتس مؤسس
مايكروسوفت التي تتجاوز ثروته المئه مليار
دولار اذا ولدت فقيرا فهذا ليس خطا لكن
اذا مت فقيرا فهذا خطا قول اخر من مارك
زوكربيرج مؤسس فيسبوك ومالك امبراطوريه
متى يقول الخطر الاكبر هو عدم المخاطره
وفي عالم يتغير بسرعه كبيره الاستراتيجيه
الوحيده المضمونه للفشل هي عدم المخاطره
ورنه اشهر مستثمر امريكي له اعتقاده شهير
صادم يقول اذا لم تجد طريقه لكسب المال
اثناء النوم فستعمل حتى تموت اخيرا نا
برنارد ارنوت رجل الاعمال الفرنسيه الذي
انتزع لقب اغنى رجل في العالم من ايلول
نصب مؤخرا يقول المال هو مجرد نتيجه لا
تقلق كثيرا بشان الربح اذا قمت بعملك بشكل
جيد فستجني الربح
[موسيقى]
دائما تحاول انك تتعلم ما تبقى عن مكانك
يعني تفتكر انك همم فهم كل شيء انه دائما
عالم بتتغير وتطور وانت لازم يعني
تتقدم مع التطورات اللي بتصير تنمي
المهارات اللي تحتاجها اليوم ممكن من
المهارات حق امس عادي
ايه اجتهاد مع نفسي
افكر افكار جديده
مراجعات جديده كل يوم جديد ممكن نجرب كل
يعني كل مره نجرب شيء جديد نحاول نغير من
طريقه الشغل اللي نسويها انا اهم شيء عندي
يكون عندي انا طموح لنا حتى لو قابلني
صعوبات في الحياه ان انا اتحدى نفسي
واتغلب على نفسي في كل مشكله بتقابلني في
الحياه ويكون دائما حاطط مستوى اللي في
المعين في دماغي ان انا لازم اوصل له هدف
ان انا هاوصل له ايا كان الصعوبات اللي
بتقابلني ودائما ان انا ما يقسم مع كل
خبطه بتقابلني لا بالعكس ان انا اتحدى كل
المواجهات اللي بتقابلني عشان احقق الحلم
اللي انا اوصل له في اي نتيجه
[موسيقى]